of course the biggest myth of sharks is
that they're all man users and probably
95% of all shark species have never
bitten a human my name is George Burgess
I serve as director of the Florida
program for shark research there are a
relatively small number of sharks that
actually get involved in shark bites any
species it gets to about 6 feet or so in
length is potential danger simply
because whether they intend to bite the
human as a prey item or just by mistake
the jaws big enough to do damage so
those are the ones were most concerned
about in the in the ocean sometimes
humans simply are the right size for
those animals to give it a shot at
because we were in the appropriate size
range and oftentimes we are behaving in
an appropriate fashion for the things
they normally in areas where seals and
sea lions are found of course we look an
awful lot like a seal or a seal and when
we're at the water service and even more
so if we have a black wetsuit on but
that said none of these species are
going after humans normally as prey time
simply because we're not part of the
food chain we're not members of the
marine environment heck we can't even
breathe underwater so you know we're
occasional when we're there we're
eco-tourists when we enter the sea so as
a result sharks are not looking for
humans as is normal prey items
you
[Music]